welcome to the ultimate video on how to
factory reset your iPhone updated for
late 2019 but before that let's quickly
go through the two best ways to backup
all of your iPhones data if it's already
backed up you can skip ahead to this
section of the video the best way to
backup your data is to use iCloud on
your iPhone go to the Settings app then
tap your name at the top of the screen
tap on iCloud and you'll see how much of
your data is in the cloud if it's full
you can upgrade your iCloud plan by
tapping on manage storage and then tap
change storage plan I personally have
the 200 gigabyte plan which I recommend
because it's only $3.00 a month and it
supports family sharing but you can get
up to 2 terabytes for $10 a month back
to the iCloud page make sure to enable
all the apps you want backed up
especially your photos contacts and
messages then scroll down and tap on
iCloud backup make sure you connect it
to Wi-Fi and then enable it tap ok and
then tap backup now once it's finished
make sure the last successful backup is
up-to-date and you're good to go now if
you prefer not to pay for a cloud
storage you can backup your iPhone for
free using itunes download the latest
version on your Mac or PC open it then
connect your iPhone using your charging
cable and make sure it's unlocked in on
the home screen click continue on the
pop-up window vents have trust this
computer on your iPhone and answer your
passcode in a few moments an iPhone icon
should show up in iTunes click on it you
should now see a summary of your iPhone
storage within the backup section switch
from backing up to iCloud to this
computer and make sure to check the box
that says encrypt local backup and then
create a password for it if you don't do
this your passwords won't be synced
forcing you to re log into all of your
apps your iPhone should now start
backing up later on you'll be able to
connect this iPhone or a brand new one
like the iPhone 11 and click restore
backup to get all of your safe data onto
your phone before resetting your iPhone
go to the Settings app then tap your
name at the top of the screen scroll
down tap on Find My iPhone turn the
option off and then enter your password
this will take your iPhone off if your
Apple
so it's ready to sell and now you can
erase in factory reset your iPhone by
going to settings tap general then
scroll down to the bottom of the page
and tap reset then tap erase all content
and settings if it's been a while since
your last backup you can tap backup in a
race or you can just tap erase now if
you recently finished backing up then
simply enter your passcode and tap erase
when it's finished resetting you're done
wait don't leave just yet
if you enjoy tech videos like iPhone
reviews and comparisons you should check
out some of our other videos right there
and consider subscribing by clicking the
circle above this has been Abidine with
max tech and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]